the male ego president i am
easy to learn risk the
belimo group with a pinch commission
europe house played blood picture peace
[music]
1 2 or 1 the world
[  music]
[music]
really
president beginning dwells a magic inside
message waiting for global change to
global challenges  of lake partners
bishop cooperation
state street corporation
trading ladies and
gentlemen the relief that many
of us feel at the change of office in
washington should
not hide one
thing president trump mark will be history in a few hours
but his supporters remain
over 70 million
americans voted for trump in the elections a
few hundred of them stormed
the capitol in washington just a few days ago
the heart of the amer  ican
democracy
these tv pictures were a shock for
all of us this is how it looks when words become deeds
this is how it looks when the rapid
digital spread of hate
messages and fake news become a
danger for democracy
we should use these pictures from the usa as a
reminder
despite all our trust in our
european democracy, we as europeans do
not feel immune to such developments,
on the contrary, we have them for a
long time now, last august, a
few hundred right-wing extremists wanted to
storm the reichstag in berlin only thanks to the courage
and prudence of a handful of
police officers, it was  to thank for the fact that they
were unsuccessful and
we remember jo kox the british
labor member of parliament was murdered in june 2016
in those heated days before the board
referendum by a right-wing extremist an
act that still stunned today of
course there are
differences to the storm on  the chapter
but there is also with us  people who
feel disadvantaged who are
angry people who cling to wildly rampant
conspiracy theories of often
confused milos completely abstruse
pipe dreams
and of course we also have
social media that spread this hate
and contempt for our democracy
unfiltered millions of times
ladies and gentlemen deputies of
course we have to  addressing the concerns and
needs of each and every one of our
citizens their fears
of being left behind economically in the pandemic
we will do this, for example with the
billions in investment and
reconstruction program next generation,
but in the end we may not be able to do
every one of them  being able to convince
that no
dark forces are at work in our democracies there is
one thing we politicians can and must do,
but
we must ensure that this
hateful messages and misinformation are
no longer spread unchecked  we must be able to ride
the unbridled and
uncontrolled power is a
political power of the large
internet corporations democratically hang in
because in a world in which
polarizing opinions have the greatest chance of being heard, the path from eccentric
conspiracy theories to dead
police officers is not far away,
and the storm has also risen  the capitol is
unfortunately shown let me first make
one thing clear so that no wrong
tongue-lashing comes into the debate how in
europe we value innovation we are
enthusiastic about the possibilities of the
latest technology we are open to
new things because without the new without the
innovation without the advances in
technology  there is no tomorrow we
will not be able to keep what is important to us
, but new technologies must never
lead to others
determining how we live and that is exactly
what this is about,
as you know, the commission
said the digital service in december and in the
digital market act  brought off
roughly v  simplified, we want to
achieve that in the future online is
forbidden what is also forbidden in
the analogue world, we
want the platform to
create transparency about how their algorithms
work, because it cannot be
that decisions that have far-reaching
effects on our democracy are made
by computer programs that are
not human  controlled and we want
clear guidelines for the internet
companies to take responsibility for the
content they spread
because that's also important to me, no matter how right
it may have been that twitter shut down
donald trump's account five minutes past twelve, such serious encroachments on freedom of expression
should stop  are made on the basis of
laws and not according to the
rules of the game of companies based
on the decisions of
parliament
politicians and not the manager of
silicon valley ladies and
gentlemen deputies especially in the field
of digital  do we in europe have a
lot to offer the new government in washington
our european way can be a model for setting the course
internationally,
just as our basic data protection
regulation has long been
i can imagine as a first step,
for example, a joint trading
technology council
together we can create a globally valid
rule book for  the digital economy
create from data protection and
privacy to the security of
critical infrastructure a set of rules
based on our values
human rights and pluralism inclusion
and the protection of privacy
grazie president von der leyen has the
cultural and political president by
himself these are michael residenz the solid
call ex-  president first day the day of
great expectations of the future of the
atlantic relationship joe biden vice
president harris the integration place
for years of splitting society center
escalation of violence against
institution steven the presence
demok  ratie neuruppin the first
messaging pictures of america in means
the unbelievable pictures of the office
of nancy pelosi message by mies förster
from the membrane parliament is a
european parliament electric
parliament but how do you explain colleges
in washington
if gerda institution of parliaments
chf democracy democracy how  we put it into
the streams